I'm the only like fiance that pimps
their Beyonce out like talk about a lot
they are six years later Miley Cyrus is
still pimping out her man
on Wednesday the 26 year old singer
gushed about her hubby Liam Hemsworth on
her Instagram story
Miley shared this smoldering shot of
Liam from the LA premiere of Avengers
end game on Monday yeah
swoon and she wrote I'm literally
freakishly obsessed with husband right
now like always has been always will be
but right now it's extra compulsive okay
so my favorite part of this post those
water drop emojis which I'm pretty sure
are supposed to be sweat droplets
because Liam is all kinds of hot pretty
pretty sexy anywho that pic of Liam was
just one of a ton of cute moments to
come out of the end game premiere Miley
also shared a clip of her licking Liam's
chest on the red carpet uh yeah licking
his chest she captioned the video when
he looks good enough to eat hashtag
snack hashtag sugar daddy I'm very
thankful and very grateful oh but the
nauseating cuteness isn't one-sided guys
Liam got in on the flirty action sharing
this shot of Miley looking annoyed
pushing his hand away as he touched her
stomach
the caption tickle-tickle Miley and Liam
tied the knot in December with only a
handful of close friends and family by
their side he caught up with Liam
shortly after they said I do and it was
clear he's a man in love my gift to you
it is a wedding gift I'm a you know take
open it up see what it is
Wow Wow it's cozy it's for when you're
watching drag race with Miley - I'll
have these people this is oh it's me
it's me my wife that's great to be wife
husband and wife it's the best it's the
best you know I feel so lucky to be with
someone like her yeah it's great very
very very lucky just a few weeks later
Miley was on wifey duty when Liam got
sick and couldn't attend the premiere of
his romantic comedy isn't it romantic
we heard hospitalized what's wrong is he
okay
yeah he'll be okay you know just you
need to take care of himself and getting
healthy is more important than anything
else so I'm here to represent I had my
dress already and I couldn't let it go
to waste
how is your life like a rom-com um that
maybe it never goes exactly how I think
it's going to but somehow it always ends
up being better is it amazing like you
and Liam newlyweds and you're here in
the premiere of is carpet how crazy is I
know so low but not exactly how I
expected it but I'm happy to be here and
represented okay I'm just gonna go ahead
and say it guys I stand for Miley and
Liam these two really are the cutest of
course we'll be here to keep you up to
date on all the cute things these
lovebirds say about each other so be
sure to keep it locked on et until next
time I'm Hallie Stephens bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]